go to the Tesla website and they're
trying to sell me a Tesla factoring in
the gas savings are they that desperate
to move the next marginal autumn unit
out desperate are they no I think that's
just a fun little thing no one buys a
Tesla for gassy thank you be honest I
mean look anyone who goes the Tesla
website and puts together his own model
comes to a price and more than a hundred
thousand dollars it doesn't it's not
like you're saving a ton of money and
gas at that price you know the marginal
savings that you get aren't really
significant frame for me the arch
question is it an auto company doing
nothing financing L Elon Musk's dreams
or is it a legitimate company from where
you sit I'm not asking to be a
Securities and well if you imeem if
you're talking about the product it's an
amazing Prado I want to know if it's an
auto company that enjoys losing money
every auto sale its financing his other
dreams like what SpaceX no batteries
hyperness knows no certainly not how
much money will go to funding the
gigafactory certainly certainly they'll
use some of it to fund some of those
things but Elon Musk has said they'll be
profitable by 2020 which isn't very far
away I know it sounds like a terrible
number but we are in 2015 now and you
know they've turned a profit in the past
it's it's it's I don't want to say it's
like Amazon but when they want to they
could turn a profit with a little
financial engineering but they'd rather
reinvest in this business reinvest in
other businesses the gigafactory for
example is gonna make a huge difference
on the future of Tesla it'll make
batteries cheaper it'll me that far is
cheaper they'll be able to offer a 34-0
search is the battery factory cash
positive at some point uh that's what I
can't get a hammer not definitely not
until you know as far away as it doesn't
matter anymore to forecast wait wait I
got us you're in Italy last weekend if
you I would you write a Tesla like every
other weekend no but they're a lot more
solar power panels over there okay I
just think give me the color on this I
mean your road and track die and all
that forget about the bells and whistles
what is your take on it as an auto
company uh well my take on it as an auto
company is they made an amazing product
that previously nobody could an electric
all electric powered car
that drives like a dream I mean it
sticks to the ground you can't flip it
over the torque is like instant on call
and it has 300-mile range which I feel
like is a lot you know I feel like 300
miles is a pretty decent mountain range
and you can charge it in a half hour
yeah it's a status symbol and to status
symbol it's a lug I don't think it's a
status symbol it's a luxury product it's
a status symbol that you believe that
global coming is real and you want to go
but you just despite Porsche does
Porsche make money Porsche makes a ton
of money it sounds profitable I or
something and they make half of it are
you going all day and look for time they
just started right they're gonna make
money by 2020 I'm escaped